[Música]
escala en París Ahí va para la
u Bienvenidos a todos a este programa de
radio Francia internacional y France 24
recientemente 190 países adoptaron en la
cop 15 celebrada en Canadá un acuerdo en
favor de la biodiversidad que incluye
nuevos compromisos sobre el acceso y la
participación de los beneficios
económicos de los recursos genéticos de
plantas y animales un tema que divide al
norte y al sur del planeta y para
hablarnos de todo esto Hoy hace escala
en París la abogada Franco peruana
Patricia Cuba sisler Muchísimas gracias
Patricia por estar con nosotros y
bienvenida gracias por la invitación
Bueno primero de todo Patricia Qué son
los recursos genéticos
los recursos genéticos están definidos
como el material de origen vegetal
animal o microbiano que contiene
funcionalidades de herencia es decir ADN
y cuya utilización puede permitir
efectivamente
un nuevo y propiedades nuevas tanto a
nivel científico o a nivel de uso
comercial en 2014 entró en vigor un
protocolo el protocolo de nagoya En qué
consiste y cómo se relaciona con estos
recursos genéticos si efectivamente el
protocolo de nagoya en realidad es un
vamos a decir se vislumbra se es un
brazo es una es una secuencia de la
convención de biodiversidad que es
precisamente la que acabas de citar la
que se celebró en Canadá la cop 15 y el
protocolo de nagoya se concentra en este
tema de acceso a los recursos genéticos
es decir crea un dispositivo para que
promuevan cada uno de los estados parte
legislaciones que permitan reglamentar
las condiciones de acceso a los recursos
y lo que le llaman una justa y
equitativa del uso de dichos recursos
Entonces
el día de hoy Son 127 países que son
parte del protocolo de nagoya y que
también se reunieron en una era la
cuarta reunión la cop cuatro del
protocolo de nagoya en Canadá en los
últimos años para situar más o menos de
qué se trata a nuestra audiencia se
democratizaron las técnicas de
secuenciación genética lo que ha
permitido que se cuece informáticamente
el ADN de especies biológicas de todo de
todo el planeta prácticamente cualquiera
no de nosotros puede puede acceder con
un solo clic en internet porque las
bases de datos de
son de libre acceso explícanos Cómo
funcionan esas bases de datos sí
efectivamente bueno es el progreso
tecnológico hace que el día de hoy ya no
es necesariamente
ya no tienes la necesidad de tener el
recurso biológico la planta la real
digamos exactamente material para
obtener el recurso genético porque tal
como lo explicas hay bancos No todos son
públicos hay bancos de información
privados pero que tienen esta esta
secuencia genética esta información de
secuencia genética de recursos y esto no
entra no estaba previsto en el protocolo
de nagoya Entonces se convierte en un
punto neurálgico del debate y la
discusión en la medida en que hay un
acceso pero que escapa a todo control y
a toda reglamentación Claro porque ya no
vas a buscar a digamos a Brasil o a Perú
la planta para desarrollar un producto
comercial sino que ya tienes esa esos
datos genéticos con los que puedes hacer
moléculas de síntesis no para
exactamente que desarrollar viral al al
sector farmacológico
al sector médico
a la cosmetología y si no están normados
evidentemente hay dos principios
elementales del protocolo de nagoya que
son uno
el acceso debe ser hecho dentro de lo
que se llama un conocimiento
previo en o sea una autorización un
consentimiento en conocimiento de causa
dice dice el protocolo eso por un lado
se dejaría de lado con esa secuenciación
genética accesible como tú dices un poco
de manera libre y el otro lado
importantísimo también es la parte de la
retribución porque
al escapar al control ya no se fijan las
condiciones que normalmente se negocian
de beneficios monetarios y no monetarios
efectivamente digamos que esas bases de
datos son muy importantes para el
desarrollo y la investigación médica por
ejemplo pero Hay muchísimo dinero en
juego Como nombraba esos sectores no
[Música]
se puede hacer pagar a estas empresas
por acceder a esos datos o es muy
complicado poner en práctica un
mecanismo de pago de retribución para
que se comparta no esos beneficios en
realidad es precisamente el punto que se
discutió en Canadá recientemente en
diciembre porque desde el 2016 las
partes de la convención de biodiversidad
estaban conscientes de esta problemática
de este de este vacío entonces lo que se
ha acordado en en la cop 15 y 4 del
protocolo de nagoya es la creación de un
mecanismo multilateral de intercambio de
información y de fondo de retribución
precisamente para poder cubrir lo que tú
estás mencionando Y hacer que haya
volvamos al principio elemental que es
finalmente una retribución justa y
equitativa para el país que es
originario
obviamente
bajo este sistema mucho más entre
comillas complejo Que es secuenciamiento
genético pero sí efectivamente es una de
las elementos claves que hay que decirlo
condicionaba en cierta forma hablabas tú
de la polémica entre el norte y el sur
para los países mega diversos del sur
era sumamente importante que se avance
con este mecanismo que está destinado a
ser pagar o hacer retribuir el uso de
esta secuenciación genética estos
acuerdos son muy importantes pero son
vinculantes o no esto hay que dejar un
poco claro no Porque de eso igual
depende también que se apliquen sí Bueno
aquí entramos un tema ya un debate más
más legal y más jurídico efectivamente
Son son vinculantes en la medida en que
los estados ratifican bueno firman el
protocolo lo ratifican y que luego se
adhieren por consecuencia a las reglas
luego hay una declinación en
reglamentación nacional y lo muy
interesante de notar es que en América
Latina los países que son parte del
protocolo de nagoya han instaurado una
reglamentación ya desde varios años y
están el día de hoy en el 2023 muy muy
activos en
reforzarla en crear mecanismos mucho más
eficaces y hay que notar también que hay
muchos estados en América Latina que no
son parte del protocolo de nagoya pero
que tiene una reglamentación sobre
acceso a recursos porque la comunidad
andina de Naciones desde el 96
lanzó una decisión tres nueve uno sobre
este tema entonces prácticamente toda la
región tiene un marco legal claro
vinculante Sí pero bueno Luego también
está el poder de creo del consumidor en
la información circula muy rápido el día
de hoy las empresas que trabajan con
recursos genéticos están el día de hoy
en una lógica de puesta en conformidad y
creo que más allá del valor vinculante
escrito de la norma Está también Esa
visión es una tendencia no exactamente
hay que subirse a ese tren tal vez para
ir con los tiempos no absolutamente es
lo que es lo que yo veo una una
tendencia de de compliance de
conformidad y que lo creo positivo es el
todo el caso lo que yo acompaño el día
de hoy empresas en ese sentido para la
zona y bueno justamente vamos a hablar
de eso como abogada usted asesora a
empresas vinculadas con con el uso de
recursos genéticos originarios
americanos de de América Latina
De qué forma se desarrolla su
intervención su trabajo la
reglamentación es nacionales
latinoamericanas están preparadas para
para asegurar la correcta protección de
sus recursos genéticos originarios hay
esa preparación sí como decías un
momento la reglamentación existe hay
efectivamente no solamente basta tener
la reglamentación hay que tener la
institucionalidad las capacidades
técnicas humanas para aplicarlo Pero hay
un hay un hay un movimiento muy muy
positivo en ese sentido podemos citar el
caso de México México
adhiere al protocolo de nagoya en el
si bien es cierto no tiene una ley
central pero tiene todo el aparato
institucional normativo para regular
este tema y apenas hace un año en enero
hace un año en enero pasado promulgó una
ley de protección de conocimientos
tradicionales que es un tema que va
vinculado porque
cuando decimos la retribución del uso de
los recursos genéticos es una cosa Pero
también hoy una retribución por ese
conocimiento
milenario
tradicional inherente al uso de tal o
cual recurso genético que merece Y que
debe también ser protegido Entonces
sí mi país Perú también tiene un nuevo
reglamento de julio del 2021 con bases
mucho más claras sólidas procedimientos
más claros sí Yo diría que positivamente
la reglamentación local regional
latinoamericana está sólida y y
preparada y lo ideal sería que
efectivamente las empresas se converjan
o no
Sí sí O sea el día de hoy hay lo
interesante del protocolo y de la
convención de biodiversidad es que hay
una plataforma de intercambio de
información una página web en donde cada
estado parte al protocolo
informa y pone el número de contratos o
de autorizaciones que ya dio sea fines
de investigación O sea a fines
comerciales y si tú ves efectivamente
Hay muchas autorizaciones que existen y
que han tenido que ser objeto de una
negociación es ahí como yo también
intervengo entre la empresa y las
autoridades locales para determinar las
condiciones de acceso las condiciones de
retribución
generalmente se fija uno por ciento del
del beneficio neto de la de la del
derecho propiedad intelectual o de las
ventas todo eso es un proceso largo pero
bien definido el día de hoy y un uno por
ciento puede suponer
dinero puede suponer mucho dinero
definitivamente
en fin yo creo que el día de hoy en todo
caso en mi experiencia personal lo que
yo veo en la región es autoridades que
si bien es cierto y con ajusto título
están muy preocupadas en el hacer
respetar su reglamentación están también
muy abiertas al diálogo a la a la
discusión
de igual a igual al final creo que tanto
el utilizador empresa gana como el país
que provee el recurso Bueno pues
muchísimas gracias Patricia Cuba sisler
por haber estado con nosotros y por
habernos aclarado todo esto Y muchísimas
gracias yo espero bueno que esa
tendencia pues pues siga no para ese
diálogo muchísimas gracias y muchas
gracias a todos ustedes por habernos
acompañado ya saben que también nos
pueden seguir por internet en rf y
mundo.com y France 24.com Hasta pronto
amigos
[Música]
[Aplausos]